freue mich sehr dass das geklappt hat
Herr Pistorius interessante Zahl
vielleicht gleich zu Beginn 49% der
deutschen das Land ist total gespalten
in dieser Frage wollen dass wir uns mit
Waffenlieferungen zurückhalten
gleichzeitig sind sie der beliebteste
Politiker des Landes wie geht das
ich glaube das geht deshalb weil ich
mich darum bemühe beide Seiten zu sehen
und zu verstehen und das tue ich
tatsächlich auch und wenn wir ehrlich
sind keiner von uns gibt gerne so viel
Geld für Waffen aus niemand von uns
würde ich lieber was anderes tun als
Waffen zu liefern in einen Krieg aber es
bleibt gerade im Augenblick nichts
anderes übrig wenn wir die Ukraine nicht
im Stich lassen wollen und auch dafür
dass wir das nicht tun gibt es eine
breite Mehrheit
das heißt sie sagen das ist der einzige
Weg ja wir müssen das so machen das ist
ja die Frage die dahinter steht also
müssten wir uns nicht alle gemeinsam
wirklich anstrengend wirklich ins Zeug
legen dass wir da endlich zu einer
anderen Lösung kommen oder anders
gefragt die Tatsache dass da in der
Mitte Europas jetzt plötzlich ein
Flecken Erde ist ein großer fleckenerde
zugegebenermaßen der vor Waffen nur so
strotzt macht ihn das Angst ja das macht
glaube ich jedem Angst und mir auch ich
bin ich habe oft gesagt ich bin geboren
zur Zeiten des Kalten Krieges bin
gleichzeitig aber aufgewachsen als
Jugendlicher mit den
Städtepartnerschaften ganz Europa die
uns in dem Glauben großgezogen haben
diese Städtepartnerschaften
gewissermaßen dass wenn man sich nur
wenn die Jugendlichen Generation sich
kennen dann schießen sie nicht
aufeinander dann war der Kalte Krieg zu
Ende die Mauer fiel das Ende des
Warschauer packtes kam und plötzlich
wachte ich auch in einer anderen Welt
auf mit Anfang 30 und hätte nie geglaubt
und so ging es wahrscheinlich vielen
anderen auch dass wir solche Zeiten
wieder erleben aber die Geschichte lehrt
uns um auch dass ein souveräner Staat
der in dieser brutalen unprovozierten
imperialistischen Art und Weise
angegriffen wird dass man den nicht
alleine stehen lässt erst mal persönlich
aber schon deshalb auch nicht weil es
eben nicht nur um die Ukraine geht es
geht um weit weit mehr Putin greift hier
nicht nur die Ukraine sondern die freie
Welt die Welt des freien Denkens der
Freiheit für alle der Demokratie und da
war der Angst
wie groß ist ihr Verständnis für die die
sagen wir wollen das nicht wir haben
Angst da reingezogen zu werden ich habe
für jeden Verständnis der sagt ich will
da nicht reingezogen werden übrigens wir
wollen und das ist klare Linie der
Bundesregierung wir werden nicht
Kriegspartei werden das muss man immer
wieder sehr deutlich unterstreichen wir
wollen nicht Kriegspartei werden und ich
habe Verständnis für jeden der sich
Sorgen macht der Angst hat der nicht
mehr mitkommt mit diesem gewaltigen
Beträgen über die wir reden das verstehe
ich hundertprozentig die Frage ist nur
die gehen diejenigen damit um also ein
Frieden zu fordern nur weil man keine
Waffen mehr fordern liefern will
aber damit einhergehen zu sagen die
Ukraine muss einfach klein beigeben das
kann ich die Lösung sein das interessant
wie sie formulieren sie sagen wir wollen
nicht Kriegspartei werden
könnten wir Kriegspartei werden könnte
das passieren wir hören mal ganz kurz
rein in einen Statement von ihnen da
waren sie noch nicht vereidigt 17 Januar
sie erinnern sich sehr genau weil das
war der Formulierung die war die war
kritisch rein
Film Verteidigungsministerium ist schon
in zivilen in Friedenszeiten eine große
Herausforderung und den Zeiten in denen
man als Bundesrepublik Deutschland an
einem Krieg beteiligt ist indirekt noch
einmal besonders und von da bin ich mir
der Verantwortung der großen Bedeutung
dieser Aufgabe natürlich sehr bewusst
und bin umso dankbarer dass sie mir
zugetraut wird und werde mich vom ersten
Tag an mit 150% in dieser Aufgabe rein
stürzen
Annalena baerbock hat eh nicht
formuliert nee
Annalena baerbock hat gesagt wir kennen
in einem wir kämpfen gegen Russland
kämpfen einen Krieg gegen Russland so
was habe ich nicht gesagt ich habe
gesagt wir sind indirekt an einem Krieg
beteiligt durch Waffenlieferung das ist
ein Unterschied indirekt heißt eben wir
sind nicht direkte Kriegspartei und wir
sind auch nicht indirekte
kriegsverteiler wir sind indirekt am
Krieg beteiligt das ist ein Unterschied
beteiligt zu sein in irgendeiner Form
weil sie merkt ja aber das erleben wir
gerade bei diesen ganzen genau jedes
Wort jedes Wort hat viele Interpretation
Hintergründe und man kann alles in die
ein oder andere Richtung
sozusagen dann meinzustellen aber ich
gehör auch nicht zu denen die anderen
Lena Bär Bock das angreifen sondern wir
merken anhand der Sprache Sprache ist ja
immer so verräterisch wie Navi da dran
sind
dass der Punkt gibt noch eine andere
verräterische Formulierung
sie sagen die Ukraine muss diesen Krieg
gewinnen Olaf Scholz sagt lukrene darf
diesen Krieg nicht verlieren wo ist der
Unterschied das ist eine Frage der
Interpretation wie wir gerade schon
festgestellt haben am Ende geht es darum
so habe ich jetzt die letzten Tage immer
formuliert Russland darf mit diesem
Angriff auf die Ukraine nicht
durchkommen das heißt wieder was anderes
am Ende geht es ja auch nicht um die
Frage wer ist militärischer Gewinner
sondern was steht am Ende und das können
wir nicht in Deutschland in den USA oder
in Großbritannien oder in Frankreich
entscheiden das entscheidet vor allen
Dingen der Angegriffene Staat der
souveräne Staat Ukraine den wir
unterstützen und die Ukraine muss
definieren an welchen Punkt sie welchen
Weg einschlägt und welche Entscheidung
treffen und wir müssen dann entscheiden
wie welchen Weg gehen wir mit ist
richtig aber noch mal die wenn sie sagen
die Ukraine muss diesen Krieg gewinnen
was bedeutet das für sie in der
Konsequenz ja eine andere Konsequenz als
zu sagen die Ukraine darf diesen Krieg
nicht verlieren ich sehe den Unterschied
ehrlich gesagt nicht okay verloren
dann wären die besetzten Gebiete weg
oder wahrscheinlich sogar mehr davon
müssen wir ja ausgehen wenn sie den
Krieg gewinnt würde sie die Territorien
zurückbekommen und keine weiteren würden
besetzt werden so das heißt im Ergebnis
ist das kein signifikanter Unterschied
es kann aber einen riesiger Unterschied
werden wenn man das dekliniert und
sozusagen cool Leber der Außenminister
der ukrainische sagt wir brauchen
phosphorbaum warum Streu Munition wir
brauchen Kampfjets
und um zu gewinnen ne und
Olaf Scholz dass das total interessant
Olaf Scholz wird ja häufig vorgeworfen
hätte so viele rote Linien gezogen und
dann jeder irgendwann wieder kassiert
die Wahrheit ist er hat keine einzige
rote Linie gezogen verbal nicht aber das
Gefühl dass in der Öffentlichkeit
entstanden ist ist genau das Panzer wir
in die Ukraine auf gar keinen Fall jetzt
machen wir es doch reden wir gleich
darüber was wäre mit Phosphorbomben da
muss ich noch mal kurz einhaken Olaf
Scholz hat nie gesagt meines Wissens
dass er deswegen niemals Panzern
aber das ist genau das Problem was wir
haben gerade in unserer Gesellschaft
wenn er es wenn er nie ausgeschlossen
hat sondern immer nur gesagt hat wir
machen keine Alleingänge wir machen das
abgestimmt mit unseren europäischen und
unser transatlantischen Partnern dann
ist das etwas anderes als zu sagen kommt
für mich nicht in Frage ist eine rote
Linie so deswegen er hat diesen Weg
durchgezogen den trage ich
hundertprozentig mit weil es richtig ist
so ein Weg nicht alleine zu gehen und
wir sehen ja gerade was passiert erst
waren wir diejenigen die man denen die
man gewissermaßen vor sich herzutreiben
glaubte genau
jetzt warten wir auf zumindest einen
Teil der Panzer die wir mit denen wir
hätten rechnen dürfen nach den
ankündigen und
rote Linien sind immer schlecht weil
rote Linie ja nicht nur einen selber wie
soll ich sagen fixieren auf eine
bestimmte Position sondern auch dem
Gegner klar machen welchen Schritt er
nur machen muss damit dieses oder jenes
geschieht aber es gibt eine Grenze in
der Tat und die sind wo ist diese knall
ich sag mal bei Phosphor und streuobern
wir haben klare wir haben und wir sind
unterzeichnet der entsprechenden
international Konventionen wir
produzieren sie nicht mehr wir halten
sie nicht mehr vor wir haben versprochen
vertraglich unterzeichnet dass sie sie
nicht mehr einsetzen das heißt wenn die
Russen das machen würden trotzdem nicht
weil so argumentieren ja du Ukraine und
sagen das machen die auch wir brauchen
das auch ja aber wir haben eine klare
Linie in all diesen völkerrechtlichen
Fragen dass wir immer sagen das rechte
stärken das nicht das Recht brechen und
dazu gehört auch dass wir uns unsere
eigenen Regeln halten und die Regeln
heißt der hatte Waffen setzen wir nicht
ein keine sträubunition keine
Phosphorbomben das wird nicht geben dann
sind wir bei den Kampfjets was mit
Kampfjet sind eine hochinteressante
Frage übrigens genauso lange waren ja
alle haben über Monate über Panzer
gesprochen obwohl eigentlich das viel
wichtigere Thema war nach Einschätzung
aller Experten einschließlich general
Millies in aus den Vereinigten Staaten
erdefans Luftverteidigung die
Luftverteidigung über der Ukraine ein
sicherer Himmel über der Ukraine ist
Voraussetzung dafür dass das
Kriegsgeschehen für die Ukraine weiter
oder noch positiver verläuft als bisher
hat aber keiner darüber reden wollen
weil es vielleicht nicht sexy genug ist
über Munition für Luftverteidigung zu
sprechen oder über deren
Aufrechterhaltung also haben alle über
Panzer gesprochen weil es so schön
griffig ist jetzt reden alle über
Kampfjets die können eine Rolle spielen
da können wir uns aber jetzt als
Deutschland so sehr wie wir im Fokus
standen bei den Panzern wegen Leopard
Hersteller Nation können wir uns jetzt
ein bisschen zurücklegen weil es um
jetzt geht die wir gar nicht haben
die wir gar nicht im Bestand haben die
wir nicht fliegen und es macht keinen
Sinn für eine Luftwaffe jedenfalls sagen
mir dass die Experten vor der Luftwaffe
die im Krieg ist sich auf mehrere
Systeme zu stützen das ist kompliziert
von der Ausbildung das ist kompliziert
von der Instandsetzung von der
Treibstoffversorgung und so weiter aber
trotzdem müssen sie eine Haltung dazu
entwickeln
der Westen der sogenannte der sehr einig
auftreten muss weil er auch gar nicht
das Gefühl entstehen darf dass wir in
irgendeine Frage diesbezüglich gespalten
sind das auch immer die Argumentationen
des Kanzlers im Besonderen sie noch mal
die Frage wenn wenn Sie sich jemanden
schließt Kampf schätzt zu liefern
unterstützen Sie das oder nicht wenn
Nation die über die entsprechenden
Kampfjet verfügen das für sich in
Abstimmung mit den anderen Partnern
entscheiden dann haben wir das
mitzutragen wir werden selber nur keine
liefern können und müssten auch keiner
liefern weil wir die entsprechenden
Mittel haben und was dürfen dann die
Ukraine mit diesem Kampfjets
oder das ist dann aber eine Frage die
diejenigen beantworten müssen die die
Kampfjet zur Verfügung stellen und das
bedarf dann klare Absprachen also alles
was dann beispielsweise
alles was dann auf originär russisches
Territorium geht und nicht nur zur
präventiven Abwehr beispielsweise
genutzt werden würde ist dann schon
heikel darüber muss man dann auch mit
den Partnern in der Ukraine reden
dass das mal durch seine wirklich heikle
Frage man könnte ja argumentieren und
sagen naja gut machen doch die Russen
auch greifen dass der rhetore Mannes
anderen souveränen Landes an und da
fallen auch keiner ob die das dürfen
oder nicht und demzufolge hätten die
Ukraine aus Verteidigungsgründen und
auch aus moralischen Gründen letzten
Endes das Recht
Dinge Einrichtungen speziell
Munitionsdepots zum Beispiel auf
russischem Territorium anzugreifen
dürften die das nur sehr eine grenzt sie
und die dann zu ziehen ist wenn sich die
Frage stellt ich halte nur nichts davon
hypothetisch ein Kriegsgeschehen
waskalieren ich halte das für unklug
weil wir damit Dinge vordefinieren die
am Ende erst dann unter ganz anderen
Rahmenbedingungen entschieden werden
müssen als wir sie vielleicht heute
haben die aber in drei Wochen oder in 3
Monaten sehen anders sein könnte das
sind Fragen die man nicht heute
entscheiden muss man muss da nicht
entscheiden aber sie denken doch genau
über diese Fragen nachher bist du sie
haben noch eine Haltung dazu ja ich
denke über viele Sachen aber nicht alles
worüber ich nachdenke muss ich auch
öffentlich reden das was anderes ne so
und ich finde die Frage um die es geht
ne das ist eine der Frage es gibt noch
viele andere die man klären kann und
klären müsste und die man intern
bespricht aber man muss sich über jedes
möglicherweise vielleicht hypothetische
geschehen oder auch wahrscheinlich
geschrieben schon öffentlich alle
möglichen Positionen beziehen weil das
die eigene
Bewegungsfreiheit auch bei Entscheidung
übrigens auch intern beschränkt von da
bin ich da immer sehr zurückhaltend
hypothetische Fragen mal eben so als
grundsätzlich ja verstehen aus dem Stand
zu beantworten ein Land für die Ukraine
das wird beschossen mit Munition ja die
gelagert wird 30 Kilometer hinter der
Grenze dürfen die dieses Munitionsdepot
die Luft jagen ist ein netter Versuch
wir können das jetzt noch weiter spielen
aber solche so einen so einen Schlag hat
es meines Wissens ja schon mal gegeben
so das wird immer wieder passieren und
ich werde jetzt keinen Persilschein für
irgendetwas noch gar nicht meine Rolle
und mein Verständnis ist aber klar das
sind dann Dinge die defensiv angelegt
sind aber eine vermeintlich Offensive
Wirkung haben entscheidend sind aber
ganz andere Frage die sich dem
Anschließen nämlich und über die muss
man dann reden beispielsweise die
Besetzung russischen Territoriums in der
Folge solche Schläge das sind aber dann
alles ganz andere Dimension und ich
glaube wir haben zurzeit andere Fragen
zu beantworten als die was in drei in
sechs Monaten möglicherweise auf
Schlachtfeld passiert es muss jetzt
darum gehen die Ukraine zu unterstützen
mit allem was nötig und möglich ist und
was vertretbar ist um deutlich zu machen
Russland Putin darf mit diesem Krieg
nicht durchkommen
wie haben sie in dem Zusammenhang den
Besuch von Joe Biden in Kiew
wahrgenommen eine großartige Geste eine
großartige wichtige Geste mehr als das
ein starkes Signal das hat es noch nie
gegeben in der Geschichte der
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika dass ein
Präsident im Kriegsgebiet das nie an dem
die Amerikaner nicht vor Ort beteiligt
sind dass sie nicht kontrollieren in
Erscheinung tritt das ist eine große
Zeichen der Solidarität das kann man
nicht hoch genug einschätzen
seit wann wussten sie davon am Tag als
er dort ankam haben sie erfahren ja
also durch die Meldung der war ja
zwischenzeitlich auch in Deutschland
unterwegs ne
nicht informiert worden darüber nein das
ist auch nicht üblich Rammstein gelandet
ne das ist auch nicht üblich
darüber muss der verteilungsminister
nicht informiert werden werden sie gerne
informiert worden das spielt für mich
keine Rolle überhaupt nicht
ich meine das da jemand hingeht und
fährt dann auch durch ein anderes Land
Zwischenlandung hier zwei Journalisten
war mit dem Wort
sagt sogar den Russen Bescheid und sagt
pass auf ich steige jetzt in diesem Zug
damit ihr es wisst und ich fahre jetzt
nach Kiel sie sagen das ist eine große
Geste finde ich auch da im Grunde
Kollege von der Süddeutschen hat das
finde ich gut beschrieben er sagte das
war so das Ende dieser verdrucktheit
sollten wir sollten wir auch zu einer
solchen großen Geste der Bundeskanzler
irgendwann uns aufraffen Olaf Scholz war
da meine Vorgängerin war da ich war da
nicht mal drei Wochen nach Amtsantritt
also dieses dieser Vorwurf der
verdruckszeit der gefällt mir einfach
nicht weil der bei der bedeutet dass
eine zurückhaltende Vorgehensweise eine
besonne Vorgehensweise das gleiche ist
wie von Druckteil das ist es nicht wir
haben eine große Verantwortung für den
Frieden für die Sicherheit in Europa für
Deutschland für die Menschen die hier
leben und da geht man nicht wie so ein
Cowboy fahren und macht dieses oder
jenes nur weil man den Applaus gerne
möchte unsere Rolle die der
verantwortlich Verantwortung tragenden
das geht vom amerikanischen Präsidenten
über den deutschen Bundeskanzler und die
anderen Staatsoberhaupt da bist Du den
Verantwortlichen Ministern wir sind in
der Verpflichtung ruhig und besonders zu
agieren und nicht den Kriegsgeschrei und
nicht in reine Symbolik zu verfallen das
sind Gesten der Solidarität die sind
wichtig gerade für die ein so tapfer
kämpfendes Volk wie die u Gewinner aber
es geht nicht darum hier jetzt sich
gegenseitig zu überbildenden markigen
Sprüchen wird hören wir einmal kurz rein
Joe Biden was er dort gesagt hat es war
sehr interessant
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie müssen ja aber alles Nachdenken
kommen gerade auch von der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz es muss Szenario
2024 ist die Wahl und dann sitzt in den
USA in Russland wird auch gewählt
da sitzt ja nicht wirklich also das was
Putin für eine Wahl hält und jetzt sitzt
plötzlich im Weißen Haus jemand ganz
anderer der sagt was soll das ist nicht
mein Krieg kümmert euch selber
dann ist das ja plötzlich eine völlig
veränderte Situation inwieweit sind wir
bereit dann diese Art von Verantwortung
zu übernehmen also das muss jedem klar
sein kein Land in Europa ist alleine im
Stande diese Verantwortung zu übernehmen
dass sie auch keiner an übrigens würde
auch ein amerikanischer Präsident egal
wie er hieße mit einer anderen
Grundeinstellung zu Europa ja nicht die
NATO verlassen das heißt die NATO
Bündnis Verpflichtung
das würde aber dann alles in Frage
stellen und dann stellen wir von der
ganzen sehr häufig über das Verlassen
der NATO nachgedacht hat über vieles
geredet über alles nachgedacht
das ist schön aber es kann passieren
dass er zwei 24 wieder über viele es
redet ja und nicht nachdenkt das kann
alles passieren aber darauf sich
vorzubereiten ist keine Sache keine
Sache von anderthalb Jahren ja also man
muss sich darüber im Klaren sein wenn
die Amerikaner das täten was ich für
ausgeschlossen hatte auch ein
amerikanischer Präsident nicht ohne
parlamentarische Rückendeckung
ist der NATO aus was ja dann der
weitestgehende Schritt wäre ich habe die
Erfahrung gemacht dass auf die USA immer
dann Verlass war wenn es darauf ankam
das war immer so überall die Jahrzehnt
ich habe selber erlebt der Kalte Krieg
die Bedrohung wir waren die Ostflanke
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
wir waren die ersten Flagge und wir
konnten uns immer auf die Amerikaner
genau so und wenn die Amerikaner mal
angenommen aus anderen Gründen kann das
ja auch passieren der Indopazifik
gewinnt dann geopolitischer Bedeutung
für die Amerikaner das heißt die
Amerikaner könnten auch im Einvernehmen
im Abstimmung mit uns zu dem Ergebnis
kommen in den nächsten 10 Jahren Sie
wenden ein Teil ihre Aufmerksamkeit mehr
an der anderen Region der Welt zu dann
kriegt genau ja genau dann tritt genau
das ein worüber ich in den letzten
Wochen oft gesprochen habe nämlich dass
wir uns als Europa als europäische
Verbündete auch europäische Verbündete
innerhalb der NATO auf den Weg machen so
und an welchen Punkt sind wir denn da
sie klanglich so unfassbar frustriert
doch doch nein sie sind dann
optimistischer Mensch sie sind ja sie
sind ja ein fröhlicher Osnabrücker aber
nichtsdesto weniger als es um die Frage
der Panzer ging plötzlich standen sie da
ganz alleine sie reden von Verbündeten
ich meine die lassen sie gerade sowas
von kalt im Regen stehen das ist
unfassbar aber es geht um 31 Panzer 31
Panzer das ist ein Bataillon in der in
der Ukraine der A6 wir haben 14 die wir
zur Verfügung stellen wollen kommen die
Portugiesen und sagen na gut wir haben
auch drei macht 17
fehlen 14 die Dänen haben zurückgezogen
die finden haben zurückgezogen die
Niederländer haben zurückgezogen und sie
sagen auf die Frage wie ist denn gerade
so läuft naja also
überschaubar wir sind hier auf mich
berauschen genau wie sehr nervt sie das
ich meine
es ist ja keine neue politische
Erfahrung übrigens auch nicht nur eine
politische Erfahrung das nicht immer
diejenigen die am lautesten ankündigen
was sie gerne wollen tun würden wenn man
sie ließe diejenigen sind die auch am
Ende liefern
diese diese Situation ich
24 Stunden im Amt noch nicht mal kam
nach Ramstein und dachte ich erwartete
geradezu dass bei diesem Treffen ich
einer Balance gegenüber Sitze von
Nationen der NATO die sagen Deutschland
macht jetzt endlich den Weg frei gibt
die exportererlaubnis und stellt Panzer
zur Verfügung und dann gehen wir auch
und dem war aber nicht so also der
Eindruck war ein komplett anderer es gab
einige wenige Nationen die sehr klar
produziert haben macht das bitte dann
können wir auch und wir sind dabei und
andere Waren nachdenklich haben gesagt
wir haben das noch gar nicht diskutiert
in unseren Regierungen wir wissen auch
noch gar nicht was wir können andere
haben gesagt wir finden es richtig dass
Deutschland so abgewogen und abgestimmt
vorgeht wie ist das tut und da bin ich
einigermaßen überrascht gewesen habe
dann die Pressekonferenz draußen gemacht
habe das auch artikuliert vier Tage
später am Dienstag das war am Freitag
hat der Bundeskanzler mitgeteilt wir
machen den Weg frei und dann dachte ich
na ja jetzt müssen ja die Nationen
kommen und sagen was ich zur Verfügung
stellen sie kamen auch A6 A4 bei A4
haben wir eine Bataillon zusammen
da sind wir jetzt an dem Punkt dass wir
gemeinsam mit der Rüstungsindustrie
klären wie schnell können wir denn
Munition zur Verfügung stellen also
nicht wie als Bundesrepublik denn wir
haben gar keine keine Panzer mehr diese
nicht mehr schon seit über 20 Jahren das
ist jetzt eine Frage die die
Rüstungsindustrie mit der polnischen
Seite klärt und wir haben die 17 A6 so
es gibt deutlich mehr
wir bräuchten 31 das ist das was wir
versprochen 31 ja und daran arbeiten wir
noch wahrscheinlich nicht zusammen
kriegen da muss man ganz nüchtern so
bleiben das macht aber nicht so
dramatisch viel aus wenn man sie gut
auffüllen kann die Bataillone mit
Schützenpanzern mit Minenräumen Panzern
das macht auch alles militärisch Sinn
und trotzdem bleibt natürlich so ein
bisschen die Ernüchterung so aber
deswegen sage ich ja auch so deutlich
seit einiger Zeit wir in Europa alle
NATO Verbündeten müssen uns klarmachen
dass wir eine andere Verantwortung in
diesen Zeiten jetzt haben seit dem 24
Februar 22
in der Süddeutschen spricht ja genau das
sehe ich aber anders Ankündigung
Maulhelden hat jemand dieser Tage
genannt
ankündigungsweltmeister
wir sind ja jetzt bereit plötzlich sind
wie diejenigen die die anderen sozusagen
vor sich her treiben oder oder Fakten
versuchen zu schaffen und diesmal der
Kontext hat historius
31 Panzer ein Bataillon und das andere
noch mal 31 Panzer macht zusammen 62 ja
dazu kommen noch die Leopard 1 sind
viele die werden aufwachsen bis zum
ersten Quartal nächsten Jahres auf
mindestens drei bis vier Bataillonen
die werden jetzt gerade hergerichtet
drei ja 120 Panzer 120 bis 130 und der
ist irgendwie das ist nach wie vor ein
sehr sehr guter Panzer er ist nicht so
modern wie zwei a246 insgesamt über 200
Panzer worüber reden wir mehr wir reden
dann ja doch etwa 200 bar genau so wie
viele Panzer haben allerdings noch die
britischen Challenger und die
amerikanischen Abrams also es kommt was
zusammen 300 Panzer auf die 300 das ist
etwa die Größenordnung vor der die
Ukraine auch gesprochen ab wann ja das
wird aufwachsen das wird nicht sofort
alles zur Verfügung stehen können das
kann aber auch keiner erwarten ernsthaft
niemand war darauf vorbereitet so viel
Material vorhalten ja so und jetzt höre
ich von Leuten die sich damit auskennen
die Russen haben wie viele Panzer in der
Ukraine ungefähr
keine Ahnung weiß ich nicht kenne die
Zahlen nicht die aktuelle 3000 kann sein
aber teilweise sehr sehr alte Modelle
älter noch als T-72 das muss man alles
auch verstehen können Kontext stellen
auch was die Nachbar trotzdem diese
schiere Masse an Material und ich höre
das in irgendwo in Sibirien warten
weitere 4000 Panzer macht 7000
ich meine wo ist das größte Verhältnis
ja wenn sie danach ginge dann hätte die
Ukraine ja gar keine Chance haben dürfen
von Anfang an auch mit unseren
Waffenlieferungen nicht also es geht
hier um die richtige Kriegsführung die
richtige Verteidigungsstrategie da haben
die Ukraine auch mit Hilfe der
Verbündeten viel richtig gemacht sonst
stünden sie nicht da wo sie heute stehen
also allein die Tiere Masse macht es
nicht wir reden wir lesen immer wieder
die Berichte über das was in Russland
nicht funktioniert was an Nachschub
nicht klappt wie die Ausbildung der
Soldaten ist und vieles andere wie groß
ist ihr Verständnis in dem Zusammenhang
für die Leute die argumentieren und
sagen Sahra Wagenknecht z.B auch ja die
die die und einige andere auch die sagen
gegen eine Atom macht aber auch gegen
eine konventionelle Streit macht dieser
Größe wie die Russen wir sollten das
lassen dass das geht so nicht wir müssen
sozusagen Einsicht in die Realität
irgendwann haben wir müssen das in
irgendeiner Form beenden weil wir können
gegen die kein Krieg gewinnen
also ich breche jetzt mit einem Vorsatz
den ich mir eigentlich vor der Sendung
genommen gemacht habe deswegen frage ich
doch Lara Wagen nicht nicht einzugehen
aber nichtsdestotrotz muss man es glaube
ich tun was ist denn die Alternative
dazu ja Alternative dazu ist wir
überlassen die Ukraine sich selbst Putin
bekommt das Signal auf den Westen ist
kein Verlass verlasst euch nicht auf den
Westen die nächsten Länder die dann auf
der auf der Speisekarte wenn ich das mal
so salopp sagen darf von Putin Stunden
wissen wir alle ob das georgien ist ob
das morgen ist ob er ob er sich ins
Baltikum traut und den Bündnisfall aus
ist das wissen wir nicht vielleicht
übernimmt er sich dann auch innerlich
man weiß das nicht gleichzeitig wäre es
ein fatales Signal an alle Autokraten
dieser Welt ihr müsst nur dreist genug
sein brutal genug sein und dann werden
die Länder die von euch angegriffen
werden über kurz oder lang alleine
stehen weil der Westen nicht dahin ein
fatales Signal geopolitisch und schon
deswegen darf das nicht passieren und da
kann man sich noch so sehr den Frieden
wünschen ich tue das auch ich komme aus
der friedenstadt aus Osnabrück wo der
westfälische friedensver behandelt
worden ist ich bin da ganz ganz dicht an
diesen friedenswurz dran aber Frieden
auf Kosten derjenigen die angegriffen
werden nur weil wir uns unwohl fühlen
weil wir keine Waffen liefern wollen
weil irgendjemand Angst hat das geht
leider nicht weil dann trifft es die
nächsten und dann sind wir aller
gemeinsam in der Enge und was sie gerade
sagen Geostrategie
zeichnen sich ja Neuentwicklungen ab
diese sogenannte Friedensinitiative der
Chinesen bewerten Sie die
ambivalent ambivalent würde ich sagen
was auf der einen Seite sind da die sind
der richtige Signale sicherlich
enthalten die entscheidende Frage ist
sind das nur Signale oder steckt
dahinter auch eine operative praktische
Politik und eine klare Positionierung
die Chinesen haben sich sehr deutlich
bei Olaf Scholz besucht geäußert was die
Frage eines nuklear Kriegs angeht und
das wäre gut wenn notwendig auch gerade
zu dass diese Linie beibehalten wird und
die klaren Grenzen werden gesetzt werden
und es wäre gut wenn konkrete Frieden
Vorschläge kämen sie formulieren im
Konjunktiv ja weil bislang haben wir ja
nur die Ankündigung aus München und der
Feuerwehr gehört ich habe die Rede
gehört ja wie haben sie die wahrgenommen
das chinesischen Vertreter der zweite
Mann hinter
ich höre von Leuten die sagen ich bin
wenn du die im ganzen Kontext hörst das
war eine Ansage das war das hat mit
Friedensinitiative nicht viel zu tun man
muss das sehr sorgfältig analysieren das
muss man glaube ich tatsächlich auch
gerade was die Frage der Souveränität
Ansprüche angeht und der Frage der
Einheit von Nationen da steckten schon
Sätze drin die man in die ein oder
andere Richtung interpretieren kann und
deswegen sage ich ja das bislang eine
Wortmeldung eine eine Ansage die aber
mit Leben erfüllt werden soll dann
kommen die Amerikaner und sagen wir
spielen dann doppeltes Spiel in Wahrheit
liefern die Waffen die Chinesen liefern
Waffen und die Russen liefern die
bislang ist mir das nicht bekannt ich
die Amerikaner haben sich glaube ich
auch vorsichtiger geräuchtet sie haben
gesagt sie fürchten oder haben
Informationen das ist dazu kommen könnte
nicht dass es schon dazu gekommen ist
bislang gibt es unterstützungslieferung
aber nicht tödliche Art also nicht
Wasser blinken mal uns gemeinsam anhören
was sehr interessant irgendwie für die
für die Frage was da demnächst passiert
bitte
einer deutliche Ansage auch und in der
deutliche Sorge die muss man auch teilen
wenn es dazu kommt wäre das eine neue
neue Lage in mit der wir es zu tun
hätten und eine die uns alle gemeinsam
bedrücken müsste definitiv und es gibt
ja Leute die sagen das alles in
abgekartetes Spiel da gibt's zwei Leute
wir sehen sie da im Hintergrund
bereist jetzt jemand nach Moskau und
dann tut man so als würde man da so eine
Friedensinitiative vorstellen in
Wahrheit ist das dann abgekartetes Spiel
Putin darüber Bescheid und dann macht
man ein Angebot von dem man genau weiß
das kann die Ukraine das kann der
sogenannte Westen nicht annehmen und
dann sagt man guck mal wir würden ja
aber ihr seid nicht am Frieden
interessiert und treibt damit einen Keil
einen weiteren Teil in diese auch zum
Beispiel deutsche Gesellschaft von der
man ohnehin weiß die eine Hälfte ist
dafür und die andere Hälfte ist dagegen
deswegen ist es so bedauerlich dass
Menschen wie Sarah Wagenknecht ihr Spiel
hier spielen und mit diesen Zuspitzungen
und diesen Vereinfachungen gleichzeitig
diesem Spiel noch Vorschub leisten
deswegen bin ich da so skeptisch und
auch kritisch muss ich sehr deutlich
sagen das ist der falsche Weg die Sorge
der Menschen vor einer Eskalation des
Krieges zu nutzen um hier ja das ganze
Geschehen eine Richtung zu lenken die
uns auch nicht gut tut als Verbündeten
als dem Westen das ist ein Spiel mit dem
Feuer
werden wir
verteidigungsbereit könnten wir uns
verteidigen ganz simpel gefragt ja die
Nase was haben Sie welche Situation
haben sie angetroffen nicht die NATO wir
die Bundeswehr was haben sie erwartet
was haben sie angetroffen jetzt sind sie
ja schon vier Wochen immer am Abend
vor der Sendung geschossen ich sagte zu
ihm äh scheiß Job nein und sie sagten
das sagen alle wahrscheinlich
interessant aber sie sehen das gar nicht
so nein weil ich glaube also erstens
jeder Job muss von irgendjemandem
gemacht werden und dann sollte es am
besten jemand sein der ihn gerne macht
er gerade in solchen Zeiten und
es ist ja kein Geheimnis wir haben 30
Jahre lang seit dem Fall dass seit dem
Ende des Warschauer packtes alle
gemeinsam außer den Amerikanern die aber
eine andere geopolitische Ausgangslage
haben uns nicht mehr um Landes und
bündnisverteidigung wirklich gekümmert
weil es nicht mehr notwendig war wir
wissen heute es schienen nur so aber das
wusste nicht kein Vorwurf man durfte
davon ausgehen
und das heißt man hat umgestellt auf
Kriseninterventionen internationaler Art
das heißt der Auftrag der Bundeswehr und
der anderen Streitkräfte in Europa war
ein anderer Bündnis und
Landesverteidigung spielte keine Rolle
Heeres Flugabwehr wurde abgeschaffen aus
finanziellen Gründen obwohl das heute
alle für richtigerweise für falsch
halten also die Entscheidung waren
nachvollziehbar aus der Zeit heraus aber
erweisen sich jetzt eben als teuer weil
die Friedensdividende die alle gerne
mitgenommen haben die sogenannte die
wird jetzt teuer zurückbezahlt werden
die Bundeswehr hatten darf man fragen
hat historisch die SPD im Besonderen
wenn sie sagen da haben wir echt Fehler
gemacht man sie erinnern die Debatte zum
Beispiel um die Bewaffnung von ein paar
Drohnen
ja wie lange hat sich die SPD dagegen
gesperrt ja aber war das ein Fehler der
im Nachhinein es gibt ja alte Spruch wir
sind alle gleich schlau die einen vorher
die anderen hinterher ja zum Zeitpunkt
der Entscheidung was was nachvollziehbar
auch wenn internationale Einsätze das
auch schon erforderlich gemacht hätten
aber niemand konnte hervor konnte ahnen
in was für einer Situation wir kurz
darauf sein würden das ist der kleinste
Fehler ich glaube insgesamt meine
Theodor zur Gutenberg hat 8,3 Milliarden
Euro bei der Bundeswehr eingespart mal
eben so das hat das und andere Sprache
Runden haben der Bundeswehr in Teilen
das Rückgrat gebrochen so nicht
unheilbar aber eben teuer wieder
hochzubringen und da mal da müssen wir
uns jetzt werden wir verteidigungsfähig
haben wir Munition wir haben mehr Waffen
haben wir wir werden verteidigungsbereit
wir hätten nicht alleine oder fähig
beides wir werden aber nicht alleine das
muss man deutlich sagen das waren wir
aber nie wenn wir ehrlich sind ohne die
Bündnis Partner Landesverteidigung
Europa war immer auch
bündnisverteidigung heute sichern wir
den Schutz der Ostflanke mit unseren mit
unseren Soldaten unserer wir werden
nicht verteidigungsfähig doch wir werden
verteidigungsfähig wahrscheinlich nicht
über einen kleinen Zeitraum nicht allein
wie lange würden wir durchhalten das
würde ich jetzt mit Sicherheit nicht
öffentlich sagen oder Wochen ich werde
darauf nicht antworten Tage nein ich
werde darauf nicht antworten das ist
meine Aufgabe das nicht öffentlich zu
machen verstehe ich ja Sie dürfen das
gar nicht aber völlig es ist auch völlig
egal weil das Bündnis auf
bündnisverteidigung angelegt ist wir
müssen jetzt nicht wieder die Szenarien
durchspielen die passieren können wir
sind an der OST an der Ostflanke im
Osten Europas in Polen in Liter und in
der Slowakei die dort französische
Brigade ein Vorzeigeprojekt mit nächstes
Jahr in bald im Baltikum und im Rumänien
üben wir stellen gerade die die ETF wir
sind am Aufbau einer Brigade die in
Teilen ständig aber nicht ganz ständig
in Litauen sein wird das heißt auch das
wir sind präsent wir machen im Grunde
genommen das heute im Osten Europas das
was die Amerikaner und andere Verbündete
bis 1990 für uns als Ostflanke der
damaligen NATO geleistet haben dann
steht ein neuer wir halten neue harte
Grenze ne da steht da entsteht eine neue
harte Grenze das sieht ganz danach aus
ja und deswegen sage ich ja wir müssen
uns darauf vorbereiten es ist keine
Frage wo wir jetzt stehen sondern wo wir
in ein zwei drei Jahren stehen müssen
jetzt müssen die Weichen gestellt werden
so schwer mir das fällt ich hätte mir
wirklich gewünscht wir müssen darüber
nicht mehr reden ja genau aber es ist
leider so die Realität ist eine andere
weil Putin es so will weil er diesen
Angriff Krieg gestartet hat und er ist
derjenige der in beenden könnte